hi everybody thanks again for popping by
this edition of just getting started as
promised stephen a smith the
multi-hyphenate the incredibly
successful maybe you might say the most
successful person in all of sports media
right now is our guest on just getting
started
[Music]
[Applause]
as promised joined by my dear friend
stephen a smith who i can say
i knew stephen a smith before he was
stephen a smith when he was stephen a
smith
i want to thank you for coming on with
me on just getting started because you
and i are old friends and when i say old
i don't mean that we are old uh though
we're old but
i've known you since before you were the
phenomenon that you are now i knew you
and you were just kind of an amazing
writer and
someone with a voice and an attitude but
watching your meteoric rise for me
has made my heart so happy
yeah well first of all love you dearly
uh you know it's great seeing you i was
just on the show with your husband the
other day and every time i see him i
smile because he always seems he always
great at what he does but he seems so
happy and we we all know you got you
have everything to do with that um but
the thing about it is for those that
don't know we were at fox sports
together
um you know at the turn of the century
we made that i was there from 2000 to
2003 and that's when we got to know each
other you were always always wonderful
to me always real and we've always been
friends ever since and it's it's more
than 20 years and counting and hopefully
it'll be 20 more years and longer than
that that we're both here well i would
hope so we had a really good time
watching the lakers
when they were the lakers
there i said it but i mean we were there
we were there for the most special three
years except for the you know you could
look back at some of the 70s lakers or
what have you or the 80s lakers
obviously we have our friend jeff
perlman's book coming out winning time
on show time this week talking about
that time but when we were there
the holy trinity of phil and kobe and
shaq every day
was a soap opera
and i don't know about you but i look
back at that as some some of the purest
times that you could really enjoy the
game of basketball and watch the
triangle unfold well i think to some
degree you're right but what made it so
pure unfortunately
is the depreciation that we experience
today everything appears to be
so choreographed everything is about
spin and turn instead of what's real
there was an authenticity that came with
shaq sometimes playful sometimes harsh
there was an all the authenticity that
came with kobe bryant and we knew how
raw he could be and how real he could
get and when they went on the court
to see them go at opponents to take
whatever ayah they were experiencing for
whatever reason out on the opponent it
was like you you just knew that it
obviously was something special sure it
came with expectations sure it being in
la and the allure of tinseltown and as
your backdrop with everything that was
transpired definitely consists of all of
that but you got to have the
personalities to back it up like for
example you wearing the purple and gold
but you're tim duncan it wouldn't have
been the same you know mr fundamental
goes about his business and you know
just just takes you apart picks you
apart win championships yeah that's
great and that would have made the town
special when you have personalities
like shaq like kobe like phil jackson
with the resume that he brought from
chicago to los angeles that all made it
that much better and then to go from
that to
you know just the sunshine you know and
just you know the beautiful weather
southern california as your backdrop as
well i mean that's that's what all made
it memorable i've never
i never ever ever cared about being out
west
until i came out here
and was experiencing those laker games
uh i was in you know in sacramento with
the uh western conference finals when
they were going against vlade divock and
bibby and petrovic
or
you know all of these guys chris webber
all of them i remember all of that and
there were some of the greatest greatest
experiences and the greatest moments i
ever had in my life some of the most fun
interviews i did
was with vlade and he'd stink of
cigarette smoke you were sure there was
vodka in his water bottle instead of
water
but some of those games up there with
the cowbells and all that we don't have
that anymore and it just made covering
that team so much fun
but
you talked about personality this
podcast is called just getting started
because i truly believe people need
inspiration they need to know how they
can turn their lives around and they
need to know how they can build so i
want to talk about you
okay how about you
and i want to know how it was that you
found a way to channel your personality
the way that you did so that you became
stephen a smith even though we know that
you are the same person that you were
when i met you and the same person that
you were growing up
so what was it in your childhood or
what was your relationship like with
sports that maybe fueled you to head in
this direction
you know i'm in the process of writing
my memoir and i talk about it in there
as well i you know my mother and father
were married
for 61 years
before they both passed away in 2017 and
2018 respectively
um i had an incredibly close
relationship with my mother who knew
nothing about sports
i did not have a good relationship with
my father who knew everything about
sports
and so
when you're young and you're a boy
you want your father's approval
and my father was watching sports
and so for me
to be
able to do sports
to
banter back and forth with him
to have an opportunity to express my
knowledge that i was gathering and
gaining
elevated his level of respect for me
to me
and as a result it helped build and
build a level of confidence and
emboldened me in ways that i don't think
anything else could have because back at
that time at a very young age because i
was struggling in school so miserably i
wasn't very confident at all
and sports essentially corrected all of
that
and my watching sports with my father
listening to his complaints and
listening to how he dissected things and
what he was saying and why and then be
fascinated because he'd say it before
the commentator called in the game said
it
so that validated for me that he really
really knew what he was talking about
and that was when i looked at the medium
itself and said wow if i did that one
day i would do it just like this
you know because
it tied in with my personality
it was real and authentic and more
importantly i felt it would have
longevity because what better way to
live your life and to pursue an
occupation than one that allows you to
be yourself that's something that's
sustainable if it works being yourself
and when i finally got into journalism
and i ended up on television you know
write for the newspapers and elevating
myself to being a general sports
columnist one of only 21 african
americans who were a general sports
columnist in this country's history to
going on radio to go on television
at the end of the day i knew that the
only way i had a chance
of having an extended
successful
career
was to be myself
and and and in all facets you know
television helps me now i was far more
serious uh back in the day because i
felt like you know what i had to show
and prove that i was worth it that i was
worthy but at this staging point in my
career it's like i'm having a good time
and i can be whatever the hell i want to
be
and all of those things i laugh i cry i
get upset you know i'm self-deprecating
i make a fool of myself it's no big deal
because these are all the things that
come along with me being me and i knew
very early on that the best chance i had
to being successful was when i was
sitting with my dad watching those
sporting events primarily yankee games
okay and knicks games i knew that was my
best chance at having a successful life
because that would require me to be
myself and i was good with that
so how did you go from sitting with your
dad and hoping to have that bond develop
between the two of you
to heading into fashion institute of
technology in new york because i'm
trying to figure out this connection
here
i was playing ball in the streets of new
york we were very very poor and i wasn't
a part of the um sponsored aau programs
or what have you so
when i played sports and i ultimately
ended up playing for the varsity team at
thomas edison high school in new york
i was five nine 130 pounds soaking wet
and i didn't have anybody knocking down
my door
for scott to offer scholarships
so thomas edison had a
tournament at fashion institute of
technology over a weekend
and i showed up there over the holiday
season rather than it was just a two-day
tournament and over the weekend um i
dropped 27 points in one game
and
the coaches there looked at me on the
spot we love you
you know we don't offer full
scholarships there's only partial
scholarships and financial aid but we we
think that you've got some potential
we're at junior college we're ranked
15th in the nation
we think that you can do something here
so
so
i you know i i didn't have anything else
anybody else knocking on my door
so i snatched at it just to make sure
that i was a part of a program
uh with plans uh to take that and and ho
ho ultimately earn a full you know a
scholarship at a four-year institution
and that's what i ended up doing once
once the salem state came along
so this wasn't like a russell westbrook
like you maybe had an inkling that you
wanted to be in fashion this was just
oh no no i didn't know i knew i wanted
to be in communication but the damn show
wasn't fashion especially back then i
was lucky if i had three outfits i
wasn't much of a fashion guy anyway
um and you know once i went to the
school you think about advertising and
what have you but it was really because
of the communications part i knew that i
didn't necessarily want to be in
advertising but what i did want to do
was be in some form of communication
whether it was print journalism
broadcast journalism or whatever
i knew that i could do that i knew that
i wanted to do that but i also knew that
i was leaving frt so the reason i picked
advertising the communications i knew
most of those credits would be
transferable so when i ended up going to
winston-salem state i had three years to
go
okay but i had accumulated
about 30 credit hours in that year and a
half
so because i did that those were the 30
credits i could transfer to
winston-salem state and i'd be able to
graduate in four years
so how good were you down there
i don't think i was very good i mean if
you talk to me about being a baller on
the street i was pretty damn good uh but
when you're playing organized basketball
you're only as as good as the time that
you spent playing and the numbers that
you produce in my case the numbers were
very low i was small i was coming off
the bench my play was sporadic i'd come
in and play and drop 20 points one game
another game i dropped two i was very
inconsistent in that regard and i was
weak mentally
because i was constantly petrified of
the coach pulling me out of the game
i've never gone against any opponent in
basketball and was scared because i
always felt that you know as my coach
would say you know coach big house at
winston-salem state later would say and
the late great john mcclendon who
invented the fast break and learned the
sport another james nate smith and all
this stuff he was a mentor to coach
gaines he used to come to our practices
and they used to look at me and say
you're the only guy we've ever seen in
our lives who takes a jump shot and is
actually shocked he misses you know you
just because i look i'd look at it i
would follow my shot i'd look like me
miss ain't gonna happen because that's
how good of a shooter i thought i was my
problem was is that i was petrified of
the coach
i always turned my head the second i
made a mistake was looking for the coach
to take me out of the game in organized
ball and as a result i was scared to
take chances because
i didn't want to get pulled from the
game whereas when you're playing summer
ball when you're playing in the streets
full court games things of that nature
no you in or you out you know you're not
coming out of the game because of a
coach and as a result i would be free
and easy and i would always be one of
the better players but when it came to
playing organized basketball the coaches
scared me so it was a valuable lesson
that i took when i ultimately got into
this business because i was able to
critique and dissect the mental aspect
of a player i knew when a player just
wasn't doing something well because they
couldn't they didn't have the ability
and i also knew when they didn't do
those things because mentally
they were knocked out because they were
scared to death of a coach of a
particular opponent even in some cases
one of their own teammates i knew all of
that kind of stuff because of the
experiences i went through
asks how would you love a chance to save
some money on insurance of course you
would after all who doesn't love a great
deal right and when it comes to great
rates on insurance for all the things in
your life geico can help
like with insurance for your car your
truck motorcycle boat and rv
even help with homeowners condo or
renter's coverage you could save even
more with a special discount when you
bundle your coverages plus add the easy
to use geico mobile app available
24-hour roadside assistance and more and
choosing to switch to geico becomes an
easy choice switch today and see all the
ways you could save with great rates and
discounts it's easy simply go to
geico.com to get a rate quote or contact
your local agent and get started seeing
how much you could save
[Applause]
i wonder how that experience being
scared
impacted you as a broadcaster impacted
you
as you made your way up because
oftentimes as you know
being scared can fuel you to achieve
heights that you've never achieved never
dreamed of achieving before
well i would tell you that
it influenced me greatly from the
standpoint that
i knew for example when it comes to
basketball i know basketball
when it comes to sports i mean i i know
football from watching it i know
baseball from watching it boxing and
stuff like that i know that stuff i know
enough of it to be able to interview you
and ask you questions and things of that
nature
but susie when it comes to basketball
i'm really asking you as a technicality
i know the answer
i just want to see whether or not you're
going to lie to me about it
that's really the difference between me
covering basketball and covering every
other sport because i know the nooks and
crannies of it all
and i also
study it in a way
where i'm looking for certain things
when i go to a team or i go to a player
i've spoken to them ahead of time about
what their definition of success is
whether i evaluate whether it vibes what
my thought of what their success what
their definition of success should be
then i judge their actions accordingly
as the season goes on and i've been that
way since day one
in my career i've always followed it
from that from that standpoint and so
when i talk basketball with guys and
they've attacked me or come at me you
know what the hell you talking about
whatever whatever we sit down and have a
conversation and by the time i say bring
your voice
since you so bold since you know let's
have this conversation and then they
quickly learn no that's not the case he
does know he doesn't know what he's
talking about even if they disagree with
me they know that i know what i'm
talking about and so those are the kind
of things that you know it influenced my
career tremendously because it gave me a
confidence i never had anywhere else
to go where's that where does that come
from where does that this confidence
come from
knowledge
experience a willingness to work hard
and not fearful
um
not being scared to admit you're wrong
you know you have to be able to do those
things there's a level of humanity that
has to come along with it you know if
you know your study you learn it
you put in the work
you have a thorough understanding of
what it is that you're talking about
that doesn't mean you're going to be
right all the time i mean because your
perspective might be off
but if you know you've done all of those
things then you can approach somebody
with the level of confidence necessary
in order to be what you need to be
based on the position that you have and
so for me
that it came from all of those things
but more importantly my experiences
because like i told you when i was
younger
i didn't have the confidence i had gone
through a lot in the home outside of the
home in the neighborhood outside of the
neighborhood you know things that i
accomplished a lot of failures you know
i got left back for crying out loud when
i was in the fourth grade so you think
about these kind of things and
when you go through all of that
you get to a point where
you're not worried about the
ramifications of being wrong of not
knowing or whatever the case may be
because you've been there before and
that you realize it's okay you all
you're gonna do is grow it's almost the
same philosophy that i use when it comes
to debating i always tell people i've
never lost a debate ever and they're
like who the hell does he think he is
i'm either right or i've learned
something new
by being wrong
which makes me brighter you know more
intelligent about that particular issue
we were approaching which means i'm a
winner because i'm gonna be better for
it than i was before we started the
debate how did i lose and that's how i
look at it
what was life like in hollis queens
growing up i mean you did grow up with
some of the more interesting uh people
in entertainment as they've made their
way through
life and some of them who have come from
very little but have become the most
successful people that are out there
well looks can be deceiving you have
you had single family homes in hollis
queens but make no mistake about it it
was poor
um in my case
it was excessively so
um holes in the roof no heat in the
house
sitting by the oven
oven open
turning on the gas just so he can
emanate from it so you don't freeze
um
rats roaches
um
you know welfare at one time government
cheese and bread
all of that stuff that you hear about
that you know that people have endured
at some point in time or another poverty
and deprecation that was a part of my
life and so
you know drug drug dealers right down
the block
crime everywhere
all of that stuff it definitely
was something that engulfed uh hollis
queens to such to some degree uh not to
the degree of projects people that's
living in the projects you know on top
of one another it wasn't as congested as
that obviously um so it wasn't as bad as
that but it was bad enough and so when
you went out into the streets
you know everybody's looking for a way
out it's going to be sports the hip-hop
john you know you know hip-hop genre
kicks in is that going to be the way out
um how you gonna get up out of here
um and your definition of success was
just essentially
trying to get
to college so you can get an education
and get a good job
you didn't fantasize about much else
which is why guys like run dmc
and ll cool j
you know these guys were so incredibly
incredibly important because
it was a different way to hit bob genre
it was a different way
you know you saw kenny smith and kenny
anderson and queen's playing basketball
yeah you knew that athletic way
uh but you were looking for any other
way that you could find where you could
dream big because for the most part
you're not dreaming big all you're
dreaming about is getting out all you're
dreaming about is getting a nice steady
job pay you a decent income but
hopefully you can buy a home one day and
be a homeowner
that was where
um
for the most part your dreams resided
and
you were just looking for a way out and
that's that's how it was growing up
so what was day one like when you came
out of school
and you had your first job and you were
on your way
my first job
in the business
was as a high school reporter for the
new york daily news
months earlier however
my brother had died in october of 1992
and i came home christmas of 1992
and i had kept in touch with the sports
out of the new york daily news sending
in clips
that i had accumulated when i was
writing for the greensboro news and
record because remember i went to
college in winston-salem but i did i had
a job as an editorial assistant
out of college at the greensboro news
record
calendar items school lunch menus birth
listings all that agate stuff that you
see in newspapers i was doing that
in my time from eight to four
and then at night
i was covering high school football for
free
just so i could accumulate clips to send
to the sports editors throughout the
country hoping that i would get a sports
writing job
and so the new york daily news um
i contacted a sports editor there his
name was kevin whitmer
and i said to him i just want to attach
a face to the name and meet you for two
minutes
and i promise i'm not gonna take any
longer and i'm big on that don't take
people don't take more people's time
than your ass because then they won't
want to give you their time
i always remember that
and so i went to meet him
and i just shook his hand handed him
additional clips said i just want to
attach a face to the name thank you for
listening to me and viewing my work and
i hope you continue to do that in the
future i'm looking for a job i'm
unemployed um but i'm hoping to land
somewhere
and he said to me and i thanked him i
turned around to walk out and he said
hey
would you be interested in doing some
freelance work
he said i have a job for you but do some
freelance work i said sure
and
the freelance work that he was paying me
it was like
fifteen hundred dollars an article
well
susie when i was in greensboro losing
record as an educational assistant i
made fifteen thousand one hundred
dollars a year
so here i was fifteen hundred dollars i
do ten of these bad boys that'll be what
i made for a year
i'm good this is good
right and so sure one article turned
into three three turned into five five
and it turned into ten ten 10 turned
into 15
uh because they liked the work that i
was doing and loved my hustle
and then i got offered a job
of an intern a met pro internship
program that was when the los angeles
times
and new york news they collaborated with
one another to offer internships
and when they did that
um
they were offering internships of 24
people
but there were 3 000 candidates i was
one of the 24 chosen
because while other people had their
resumes
i had 250 published clips from my
internship at the atlanta journal
constitution winston-salem journal
greensburg as a record
and so they hired me
um they wanted me to come on as an
intern rather one of the 24 and i went
to the new york daily news and i said
this is an opportunity for me to be a
full-time reporter it's pretty hard to
turn it down and he said would it be
hard to turn it down
if we offered you a job as a full-time
sports writer covering high schools
and i said okay
you know what we talking about here you
know
no disrespect i'm appreciative about
that opportunity he said we'll pay you
fifty three thousand five hundred
dollars
fifteen hundred fifteen thousand one
hundred dollars
fifty three thousand five hundred
dollars i think i'm gonna take the fifty
three thousand
and that's how it all started
and i went from there and
here i am
why do you think you resonate so much
because
i believe it's because
people know they can trust me
to say what i truly mean
it doesn't mean i'm going to be right
it doesn't mean they're not going to
disagree with me
but they know they can trust me to be
who the hell i say i am
that when i say something i actually
mean it
and i'm not saying it for a fact and i'm
not saying it for ratings and i'm not
saying it for clicks or just so you can
read my article i want you to do those
things because i want to get paid but i
mean what i say
and
i'm fearless with it
and i think that they see
this fearlessness um that i'm that i
approach this courage that i approach my
job with and i think you combine that
with the fact that
i say the things that people think and
say off the air but they don't believe
can be said on the air
i think that's how it all started and
the fact that as i climbed
i've still remained that guy
that part of me has not
has not betrayed them
i think that's the answer to your
question i wonder why you appeal so
broadly
across different spectrums why you
appeal
it seems to black and white audiences
equally why
do you believe that is the case i think
that what i just said
i also think the fact that
um
i'm fair
i'm a black man and i am proud
there's nothing else i'd want to be
and i love my community and i love my
people i love where i'm from i love my
culture i love who i am but that does
not mean i'm going to be unfair to
people who look different than me who
come from different backgrounds and have
different identities and cultural
backgrounds and stuff like that no right
is right wrong is wrong
and
people know that about me
there's plenty of times you know i think
one of the people think that this is a
bad thing and
they don't know me very well
i've got
white folks at time calling me racist
i have black folks at times calling me a
sellout a [ __ ]
well that means both sides have a
problem with me
good
because last time i checked
when you sign up to become a journalist
you're not supposed to care
what you're supposed to care about is
being in tireless pursuit of the truth
as you see it according to the facts
that are presented to you that's what
you're supposed to be doing
that's your obligation
and
when people come at me like that it's a
reminder to me that i have fulfilled the
obligation that i signed up for
i signed up
to be a journalist
i signed up to be somebody that would
pursue truth
and in pursuit of that truth would be as
fair-minded as i could be
in acquiring it
and disseminating it
and i think that i have lived up to that
throughout my career and so
knowing that about myself
yeah you're gonna have people who love
and hate you but you're also gonna
you're gonna you'll have people who hate
you but you're also gonna have people
who love you and they're gonna be people
that come from different communities
that don't necessarily look like you or
whatever because they're going to look
at you and they're going to say he's
fair and guess what as a black man what
am i asking from different communities
throughout this country to be fair how
can i ask of that anyone of that if i'm
not willing to do that myself what's the
greatest misconception about you
that i don't care
um
that
you know when people think that uh
i'm cruel
i really check myself i think about that
real quick
because i don't want to be that way i
want to be straight up
i want to be
no nonsense no bs
but i don't want to be cruel
i'm not that guy um
i want people to be able to feed their
families i want people to smile and
laugh have a good time
i don't want to contribute to people's
demise i've never rooted against anyone
i root for me i root for people to
succeed but i don't root against anybody
um i think that's a misconception yes
and i think the biggest misconception is
that i'm screaming all the time that is
far from the truth
i mean i'm i'm pretty damn mellow when
i'm away off camera but on camera i
would you're saying call i'd call you
quiet
i i you know i wouldn't go that far i
can't be but
the biggest thing about me is that when
i'm on the television or in front of the
microphone for radio or anything else
i'm asking you to listen and watch me
if i'm not excited about
doing it why should you be
so
it's it's you know the biggest thing is
not judging a book by its cover and not
ever thinking i'm one dimensional
because i am not a one dimensional dude
i don't believe in it i don't like it
i don't like one dimensional people i
think versatility is always the way to
go as opposed to being a one trick pony
and i pride myself on being versatile
what haven't you done that you want to
do
i want to host
my own late night show i know i did it
one night filling it for jimmy kimmel
but that's a dream of mine i want to
host a late night show
um and uh
i want to build my own production
company
um
and i you know i think about that a lot
and i even might entertain getting into
some more acting but the biggest answer
to your question is to host a late night
show
that's what i want to do i want to
celebrate the greatness that people are
putting out here in the world of
entertainment for years and years to
come i want to be somebody
um like jimmy kimmel i want to be
somebody like you know uh stephen gobert
and jimmy fallon and those guys i'm
always going to be stephen a i'm never
going to try to be anybody else but when
i say be like them and i mean in terms
of enjoying the success
that they have rich fully earned you
know they they laugh they make us laugh
they bring joy to our lives uh they make
life a lot of fun they remind you that
even in serious times
there's always a reason to smile there's
always a reason to look forward to the
move to tomorrow and i think that what
they've done for our society as a whole
uh is underappreciated i know it i've
always suspected it but i certainly knew
it tonight that i jimmy kimmel blessed
me with the opportunity to host this
show
and that's something that i'll be
eternally grateful to him and walt
disney for allowing me to do that
because it was one of the greatest
experiences of my life
what's your last thing what's your
what is your advice that you would give
those who are listening to this watching
this who were kind of looking for some
inspiration so that they can get just
they can just get started as well
believe in yourself
understand who you are and understand
that
people who are in your path trying to
stop you
they're supposed to be there
god tells us all
we can have a lot of things in life we
can prosper we can be fruitful and
multiply we can do all of these things
he never said it comes without effort he
never said it comes without sacrifice
and he never said it comes
without struggles along the way but it's
there to validate for you and your own
mind that when you finally achieve the
things that you have been after
you never question it because you know
you earned it
life is about what you earn
not what's been given to you because
even when it's given to you somebody had
to earn it to be in a position to give
it to you to begin with
be humble be appreciative of that put
your head down keep grinding and love
the journey
love the journey more than anything
because guess what the journey is what
it's all about if you achieve something
it's there it's done now what
what you got to hold on to is the
journey that you travel to get to that
point that makes you who you are
even more than you thought thought it
would remember that and continue to
march forward can you imagine that
little boy that you used to be
knowing who he is now no
what would you tell that little boy i'm
truly blessed i'm very very lucky
the only negative that i can genuinely
say
about my life and where it is now
is that my mother is not here to enjoy
with me
that's it
there's nothing else that i would
complain about no matter how tough it
gets
there's nothing else that i would
complain about the only complaint if i
looked if i had the opportunity to look
god in the face and be like if there's
one thing i wish i had right now
is that she was here to enjoy it
that's it can't tell you how much i
appreciate the talk with you i just feel
like i'd love to have people get to know
you a bit the way i know you
so selfishly speaking i'm glad that we
got to take this time
well i appreciate it but you know me
because i love you and i wanted you to
know me there's a lot of people that
don't want to know me i like them
guessing
that was stephen a smith on just getting
started it was really nice to have him
in because i feel like as i said to him
i know
a different side of him than people see
when they watch sportscenter or first
take or what have you
he's not loud
he's thoughtful and impactful and
supportive and
we had a lot of really great
nights watching
that lakers back to back to back
and just watching all the teams that
came out in the drama drama
talk about drama he's in town in los
angeles to shoot general hospital so
for those of you that love him on
general hospital he will be back in this
recurring role he's been on it four
years
he was also and i think i love my wife
with chris rock he can act the man can
act
he's a multi-hyphenate what can i say
i hope you've enjoyed this edition of
just getting started many more that came
from some diverse names from all across
sports and entertainment as always if
you have ideas that you want to
have some people be interviewed reach
out to us at just getting started we
will be populating a twitter account
shortly because god knows i don't have
my own because i just cannot stomach
social media that much probably the
wrong person to have a podcast but what
can i say
but love to hear from you as well but we
will be back to you shortly with just
getting started more guests more great
names right where you found this very
podcast thanks for dropping by and
taking the time see you soon